[Music]
15 plus 10 here we go block against 1824
handy
all right let us play sicilian
and let's see how the accelerated dragon
holds up at this level
which is my sort of official sicilian
recommendation okay so we are facing an
elephant okay i like it we haven't faced
too many elephants
so far in the speed run and you guys
know that between
d5
and knight f6 generally my
recommendation is knight f6 but
in this particular instance i want to
show you guys an interesting line
that i think is very practical and is
not that well known by a lot of players
and it starts with d5
and you can get this line
through uh the two d5 move order you
don't have to play two knight c6 okay
never mind e5
that's a weird move and
the point of this move i i think is to
move order us into a french and the verb
to move order means to basically suck
you into a line
that you don't play in this case the
french advance
white wants to play d4 so if we go e6
here white goes d4 and you get into a
french so what you need to ask yourself
is what you know if this forced a
transposition to a french everybody
would
everybody would play this right so what
could it be that allows us to get an
improved version of the french well if
you think about it that way then you
should come up with the fact that the
light squared bishop right you don't
have to close it into the movie six you
have the option of developing it outside
of the pawn chain with bishop f5 or
bishop g4 and then playing e6 and
getting sort of an ideal version of the
french between g5 and g4 and f5 i like
both squares i feel like the more
ambitious move is bishop g4 just because
it pins the knight and puts pressure on
the pawn
so
i feel like bishop g4
challenges white the most and if white
plays d4 then we play e6 and we get a
french on steroids a french with a
bishop outside of the pawn chain i mean
what else needs to be said
what else needs to be said bishop b5
that's a good move white develops the
bishop to b5 and you might ask yourself
well is bishop takes c6 check a threat
well technically the answer is no but i
don't really want to ruin my queenside
pawn structure if we have a choice not
to and in this case we have a relatively
simple move that reinforces the knight
and takes the sting out of bishop takes
c6 shot we're not in a huge hurry to
play e6 here so we can afford this kind
of nicety well queen b6 is one option
but i i like the move queen c7 as well
because the queen on c7 is just a little
bit less vulnerable and it puts more
pressure on the e5 pawn so let's play
queen c7 here hopefully everything i'm
doing is making a good deal of sense and
then our next move is going to be e6
then we're going to work on our king
side and we're also going to keep an eye
on the e5 pawn okay so bishop takes c6
well the whole reason we played queen c7
is to be able to capture with the queen
and we've got a great position our
opponent is playing very very fast d4
well again we've basically gotten a
you know a french on stairs and we have
a choice here we could play very
tactically if we wanted to so what i'm
noticing is the x-ray and there's no
name for this this isn't really an x-ray
but let's call it an x-ray between the
black queen and the white bishop that i
notice every such relationship between
two pieces and immediately that gets the
wheels turning and i'm telling myself
what about c takes d4 with the idea of c
takes d4 bishop takes f3 and then the
you can also play bishop f3 immediately
and queen takes f3 c takes d4 wins upon
because
uh c takes d4 is impossible
but this is some very high level
thinking what i don't like about that
option
after bishop f3 queen f3 cd
is that white simply castles and i'm
afraid that because we're not developing
our king side and white has already
castled
and our queen on the c file i hope you
can kind of forecast how that could be
problematic if white quickly gets a rook
to see one we're gonna have to waste
more time and get the queen off of there
i don't want to cut it too close we'll
probably be fine but i see absolutely no
need for us to play those games i think
we should just play the simple e6 and
this is a judgment call notice that i
did this virtually without calculating i
calculated only up until castles but it
was an intuitive judgment call that i
made sort of based on my understanding
of these positions overall bishop e3
now i play the karaoke on a fair amount
on my speedrun and those of you who
watch the karokon videos very carefully
should know
what the typical methods are for
developing this knight and this bishop
who can tell me where the knight often
goes in order to then make space for the
bishop
well first we go 97 but what's the final
destination yeah we do go 97 but the
final destination is either g6 but
usually f5 so in this case yeah in this
case we should go knight f5 and this
puts pressure on the d4 but now we're
not much better here i would say that
black is maybe slightly better if white
plays this well then white should be
able to equalize so don't think that
we're like winning or anything of that
nature knight bd2 good move okay so i
have a really interesting idea here what
is white one what it what is white's
next move very likely to be think about
it
well probably h3
right because bishop h5 walks into g4
but if you think about that for a second
if we calculate bishop h3 bishop h5 g4
does that actually win a piece so let's
say it's white to move h3 bishop h5 g4
does that win a piece
no because we can take the bishop
and then we can drop our bishop back to
g6 and as a result of that white has
tremendously weakened uh the king and so
we don't need to take any action against
h3 worst comes to worst we can take the
knight with our bishop but i want to
preserve all light square bishops so
let's go bishop b7 i'm really
anticipating h3 here i feel like that's
what yeah bishop h5
and now i'm really hoping that our
opponent will think that he's won a
piece no i don't like h3h5 there's no
need for us to stack there maybe it
works but
i don't see the point of that
rook c1
doesn't seem like this move accomplishes
all that much so we could play the move
c5 c4
and close down the queen side and kind
of make rook c1 look really really dumb
now the drawback of going c4 of course
is that you've basically relinquished
the pressure on the d4 pawn
but on the other hand you could argue
that the d4 pawn is very well protected
so maybe we don't need to keep putting
pressure on that pawn we've got a lot of
good moves here we can play
rook c8 for example we can play we can
just castle king side we can just castle
king said that's also fine but i like
the prospect of going c4
because it's almost a psychologically
difficult move to handle because our
opponent starts getting frustrated well
i just played rook c1 now that rook's
not doing anything
and
you should all be familiar with the
structure and you should all know that
one of black's typical plans
is to start advancing the queen side
pawns b5
a5 b4 creating
you know in in the ideal scenario a very
very dangerous queen side attack b3
basically helps us oh but we actually
have i think a way to win an exchange
wait let me think
i think we can win material here no so
b5 is the typical mode b5 is which you
play if you're
sort of you want to play typical but but
but you can actually try to win material
here i don't know if it's worth it
though i don't think it's worth it i
just want everybody to be aware of this
move the move bishop e7 to a3
this is a common idea that arises when
white plays b3 in these types of
positions so you can play bishop a3
and if the rook moves to c2
you can drop the other bishop back to g6
creating an x-ray the rook is
essentially trapped so it's very hard
for white to stop us from taking the
bishop
and then winning the exchange
but
that could be a little bit gimmicky
there are some tactical details there
which i'm not sure are in our favor
so
let's play like a russian schoolboy
and let's go b5
and after the game we'll check out
bishop a3 but here i just want to play
classic traditional
solid chess without going for
you know two overly adventurous ideas
i just wanted to okay a4
well
i think we should just play a6
although even here bishop a3 oh you know
what else i think we should do no i know
what we should do
i know exactly what we should do now
this is a very unconventional type of
move
you don't usually play this move in
these positions
the move that i'm thinking of is b takes
a4
b takes a4
now why is this move usually not played
because generally it's not a great idea
to open up the queen side like this but
in this particular instance white is so
passive
that i think opening the b file is in
our favor
and if bc then we play dc we're up upon
in this pawn we can establish on a3
so hopefully that high level logic makes
sense also note that this pawn on a4 is
now extremely weak so now we should
complete our development we should
castle and we don't need to play a five
the move a5 i know is a instinct for a
lot of people but we don't need to play
it are we really afraid that white is
going to play a5 is that
you know particularly scary i think the
answer is no how should we continue
rookie 1 doesn't seem to do all that
much so we can continue with our general
plan of action
well we don't need to play h6 that
doesn't do anything we can take the
bishop i think now would be a good time
to take the bishop we can take the
bishop but we don't have to we can keep
the tension i i yeah let's go rook b8
let's go rook b8
you want to delay taking the bishop
because bishop f4 i guess is possible
but that's not so dangerous
and we could play knight h4 wants that
okay
knight f1 white is stretched very very
thin here
so
we can infiltrate in a variety of
different ways
let me think about this for a second
i think i know what i want to do
yeah so i think what i want you can go
rook b3 or rook b2 but i think we should
revert back to our old idea right now we
should play bishop a3
and this does
many different things at the same time
if white goes rook a1 we have bishop b2
with a fork okay that's easy white makes
it very easy on us we just go bishop b2
with a fork against the rook and the
pawn i'll explain after the games the
other sub-variations and again
there are many ways that we could have
continued the attack there is probably
three or four very good moves in that
position so don't feel stressed if you
had a different movement line it
probably is also good like rook b2 rook
b3
all of those moves are probably
sufficient as well i just think this is
the most concrete
and notice how long we kept the tension
between the knight and the bishop was it
strictly necessary to do that no
but it creates
you know massive unpleasantness and
people just don't like facing the
prospect that we could take on e3
whenever convenient for us that creates
more pressure creates more tension in
the position people don't like facing
that so
i think it was important that we did
that
there was no reason to take the bishop
now our opponent starts thinking but
it's too late
we're okay too so now we uh
can eat up the pawn and already it's
almost winning
that's that
bucko so
rookie two now these types of positions
you don't want to play around with your
opponent you want to just win
what should we do
well you should consider the drawback of
rookie 2 rookie rookie 2 severs the
connection between the queen and the
knight well why does that matter well it
matters because now we can take the
knight and totally destroy
white's pawn structure but it's not
enough just to see
what the move does visually you also
have to consider all of the
accomplishments of that move the second
thing that that move accomplishes is it
removes the defender
from the d4 pawn
now that pawn has two attackers
and two defenders which means if we can
attack it one more time chances are
white is not going to be able to sustain
that pawn given how passive white is to
begin with
can we do that knight h4 white can play
knight h2 and defend the pawn you guys
are going after the wrong pawn yeah so i
love the move queen b6 now alternatively
we could also double on the b file we
could play rook b3 and rook b8 and
infiltrate down the b fall we don't need
to rush with with queen b6 i think the
classy move here
sorry i think the classy move here is
rook b3 in my opinion the classy move
the move that removes all doubt
is rook b3 we normally want rooks before
queens and we might not even need to win
the d4 pawn we might just be able to
play rook b8 and rook b1 and the
problems will solve themselves
92 here we can just take the knight i
think
and then we're gonna have like the best
knight against the worst bishop
this also protects the bishop which
eliminates any potential fork issues not
that there were any to begin with
because if white's queen moves then d4
is lost this is completely lost for
white
okay
knight g3 is a good move though
let me think i think one of the most
challenging things to teach
is the concept of transforming the
advantage like one second i just said
we want to attack
the d4 pawn but now i've noticed that
when the knight moves away from f1 what
do i see i see the fact that the king
and the queen are now aligned on the on
the uh
um on the first rank
well how does that impact my thinking
process well it makes me realize that if
we can go rook b8 and rook b1
that is now
particularly devastating that is now
particularly devastating so all we just
need to do is go rook b8
but notice knight takes f5
we have to recapture the knight because
there is a fork threat on e7
but then the threat of rook b1 is going
to be utterly devastating we don't the
knight has done its job
the knight basically says okay i've done
my job
now i'm going to delegate the rest of
the game to my other piece okay he
doesn't even take the knight this move
loses immediately we have a nice little
finale okay we can make many different
moves we can play knight h4 check now
yeah let me think what the fastest win
is
okay so i know what we should do we
should go knight h4 check
now we could take the pawn on f3 or we
could play rook b1 first i like rook b1
first because that's maximally flexible
rook b1 first is most flexible
let's throw this in
and the reason i say that after queen c2
we have a really really cute move after
queen c2 it's not knight takes f3 check
we don't we can play knight takes f3 and
knight takes deeper but
oh man we have so many cool cool things
we can do what's the cute move
what am i thinking about
so it uses the concept of knight takes
f3 but we make a preliminary move first
first we play bishop takes d4 and if
bishop d4 then we take on f3 and take on
d4 with another fork and notice that
white cannot defend the f3 square like
white literally cannot defend the square
this is over
and oh my god i'm oh my god there's a
there's a mate here that's gorgeous
okay i'm really hoping that white plays
f4
okay
cooperate with me please i really hope
that white plays f4 here and doesn't
resign i'm like praying that we get a
chance to mate like this but it requires
white to push the f pawn i guess we
could take on f3 it requires white not
to resign
that's how i'll phrase it it requires
white not to resign god i love this mate
i love these mating patterns nothing
insane but it's really really nice this
was a nice positional game actually i'm
pretty happy
happy about the quality
rook a3 okay this
yeah i mean this uh
might work i'm gonna violate a golden
rule of speed and i'm gonna try to like
manufacture this mate
so first we take on f3
step one
now we come back to h4
now the best move is rook b2 winning the
queen
but for the purposes of this speeder i'm
going to take the bishop
and then i'm going to push my pawn to d4
oh but no that doesn't hm
okay rookie three
yeah
i mean it it's not really going to work
i'm afraid
not with the rook on a3
let's just win normally i'll show you
guys after the game
i don't want to play around too much
because i don't want to mess this up and
we just played a really nice positional
game so let's just go rook b2
does this move make sense you're just
going to take on f2 if the queen moves
and that's check that's literally
checkmate if the queen moves he gets
mated on f2
it is it's fine
we'll get more chances for nice wins
sometimes your opponent doesn't
cooperate
okay i've had i had a game once where i
had probably my nicest combination ever
and my opponent was a gm and he didn't
cooperate he played like the lamest
possible move that just went down in
exchange
it would have been my
my like greatest combination ever with
like sacrificing a gazillion pieces
i can show you
maybe we can still get this pattern but
i don't think so
camera froze okay
sorry
okay
now this is just up a queen
let's give him a check force him back to
uh h2
now let's shove this pawn up to d4
and now
again we can win this in
585 different ways but the sort of
material the business-like approach just
oh wait no no knight of three what am i
saying okay we can
what i like is g5
i like the move g5
because g5 creates lift
for the king and also protects the
knight and that ensures that we are not
going to get mated on the back rank
this is like the i mean business
approach i'm not messing around that
kind of thing
yeah this is so resignable
and if rook takes d4 then we have
checkmate on g2
and otherwise we push the bonds
and by the way as a
piece of advice if you're not
if you're a beginner and you're not
totally confident
like winning a position like this you
can just play it out against the
computer
i don't know if chess.com has that
functionality i know lee chess does
you can
do a study and then you can click
continue from here with the computer
um
and i
recommend that as a training tool which
nobody actually does
at all ever
um but
it's an incredibly effective tool to
like learn
how to win certain positions
chess.com does have the future i'm sure
it
did okay very few people in my
experience do it but if you do
then
you're you're doing it right
okay so you can do it on chess.com
okay this is uh too much i think our
opponent is just this is the downside of
the speed run time control being 15
minute
largely because
this happens and we're just gonna have
to wait it out
and now our opponent starts thinking a
little bit too late
f3
okay i mean
just go c2
promote
quick analysis
we're over 1800 good stuff
yeah so this line with d5 we didn't get
a chance i didn't get a chance to show
what it is that i wanted to play against
he takes d5
the line that i wanted to play is d4
now listen carefully
cd
cd and e7 e5 this is a line
which you can play against the elephant
now white is slightly better with ideal
play but a lot of people who play this
casually don't know it
and the point is that if white plays d5
you trade queens
and now you play
bishop g4
and in return for the pawn black gets
very obvious and very strong
compensation the king
is weak black is about to castle
queenside you're threatening to win back
the pawn
you can analyze this on your own but
this is good
white has to know knight c3
now you play the typical bishop b4
bishop d2
trade trade and you play e4 this is like
the
line and now white has to know 95
and then you play 95 d5 and 97
and
in this position white can get a very
small advantage with like perfect play
but
this is a good line just to look up for
about an hour and to have something as
an alternative to
whatever your main line is against the
elephant
in any case
just like note this down perhaps uh john
clara if you're a sicilian player
thank you for the stuff so e5
now bishop g4 getting the bishop outside
of the pawn chain
it should be five queens c7 we're
following a couple of games according to
opening explorer
bishop takes c6 queen takes c6
d4
now the funny thing is the main move
here is g6 i am seeing 12 games
and for some reason everybody went g6
that's a weird move
i feel like e6 is a lot more natural
bishop e3 knight e7
now dc5 is almost never scary in these
types of positions although perhaps i
shouldn't have allowed it
i probably should not have allowed it
um because knight f5 i can try to keep
the pawn of b4
and this leads to a very complicated
pawn structure that occurs in the karo
khan if this
structure occurs in the karaoke on the
bovine karl's variation
this is the exact structure which often
occurs so if you play this line with
either color this line with c5
you get something very very similar
and there's e6 in this position but
there's also a line where you play
knight c6 and bishop g4
and you often get this is one of the
main lines actually
knight g7
bishop b5
this is one of the main lines and often
white goes before here so you can see
the resemblance in the structure
um
and yes white is up a pawn but black has
very active pieces in return for it
so
it's it's quite double-edged this
position i won't delve into it too
deeply but
suffice it to say that dc is often not
that scary you can also play knight g6
by the way
if you want to restore material balance
you can play knight g6 and go after this
pawn
anyways our opponent didn't do it he
gave us a little break we go knight f5
knight bd2 bishop e7
yeah and here very important detail that
g4 doesn't actually win the bishop
because if takes takes then we have time
to go bishop g6 and now the very typical
idea would be h7h5
to use this pawn as a hook and and to
continue assaulting white's king here
and we could absolutely castle queenside
i i totally would castle queenside in a
position like this
white is in big trouble here just
because of the weakness of his structure
and the fact that the king is really
really vulnerable it's bad
um i hope that makes intuitive sense
so rook c1
now we decided to close down the queen
side with c4
and after b3 i wanted to show
uh the idea of bishop a3 now this is a
pretty common idea that occurs in many
different openings
because just if you go to the starting
position if you think of it from a broad
standpoint
the rook on a1 it doesn't have a lot of
squares like even when the knight and
the bishop are developed
the rook on a1
often only has a little sort of
very
few squares that it can move to if it's
attacked by a dark-squared bishop
and you can trap the rook like this and
win an exchange in a variety of
different openings
here's an example
um of one of my games against a strong
player casa corley is also a good friend
and a streamer
where i trapped his rook just like this
in a in a slightly different opening
so here it is
just a moment
to the chess space
all right good
thank you gershman for the prime thank
you everybody for all the subs so in
this game there was a ragazin
ragazen is this variation with bishop b4
and
okay casa plays already a a dubious line
c d e d and bishop f4
and i knew what to do here i went knight
e4
roxy one knight c6
and and here white has to go e3 and
develop quickly but caso and g3
and now i played a very clever move i
played the move bishop f5
okay guys i went bishop g2
and what did i do in this position
so the idea bishop f5 apart from just
developing was to control the b1 square
so i played knight c3 bc and bishop a3
and the rook is trapped rook a1
there is bishop b2 much like in the game
thank you for the bit standard average
get the hype train rolling
um casa ended up sacrificing the
exchange of the rook b1 but the
compensation was
very insufficient and i ended up winning
the game pretty convincingly
in fact i think i won
yeah like i think you resign in a couple
of moves
yeah he's very very strong but just to
give you some context on like
where this idea occurs and so that's why
when the move b3 is played i'm already
primed to look for
this kind of concept of of bishop a3
okay
so would bishop a3 have won a
a rook or an exchange maybe rook b1
you can actually take the bishop first
and then play bishop g6
so you can do this and it's really very
very similar
but i was a little bit worried here
about something like e4
d e4 knight h i mean it just seemed a
little bit messy for me
and i wanted us to play
positional pure chess
um
so we decided against it but bishop a3
was something to consider
and here
most people would automatically play a6
and a6 would be fine black is still
better but in this particular instance
we play b takes a4
and the point is that if bc then dc
our queen opens up and this a pawn is
going to move to a3
and it's going to be defended by the
dark squared bishop so this pawn is
going to be a monster
a good example of like violating not
violating a rule but making a
non-standard move because the
circumstances of the position demand it
not that again not that a6 would have
been bad
so b-a-b-a we castle and the rest is
very simple rook ab8 getting it to an
open file
and now the move bishop a3 comes in and
the reason i saw this i saw this line
first
and the thing is if white moves the rook
elsewhere rook c2 actually gives up the
a pawn
it gives up the a pawn yeah f6 is
another way to play this position but we
don't need to open another side of the
board we already have the queen side and
we're already dominating there you don't
need to over you know put too much salt
on the dish
you're already good and if rook b1 then
we can take take we can throw in bishop
takes f3 and then we take another pun
just look at this position like you have
an extra pawn
it's a passer white's king side is
ruined so no matter where the rook moves
white loses material
rook a1
there should be two
and that's it we win the pawn then we
ruin the structure then we get our rook
deep into white's territory we double
rooks
and i want to go
uh to the mate so bishop takes d4
i was really hoping for f4
and the idea that i had was to take the
bishop
and who can tell me what the mating
sequence is here and this is not totally
forced but
nonetheless this next move is really
pretty
now you have to see this idea the fact
that the queen is blocked by the own d
pawn so you play d4
and if e takes d4 knight f3 check
obviously wins the game and very quickly
but the mate is what
do the honors
and i'm sure that i can find examples in
real life of exactly this kind of mate
probably with the colors reversed
one moment i'll try to find it
queen g2 check very nice
boom boom checkmate classic right it's
like a smothered mate you force the rook
onto that square and then you give mate
with a knight
and then you give a mate with a knight
okay here's a good example so zhu
zhinxiao is a chinese grandmaster i've
played him before
he's playing chuzzo prakashian
world youth under
16.
okay
so this position occurred obviously
white is winning white is up a pawn
but it looks like there's plenty of
chess left to be played what did white
do in this position and this is not
exactly the same idea but it's very very
similar
can anybody see the mating pattern
can anybody see the mating pattern and
it's not there's a move here that sets
it up it's not immediately a queen
sacrifice thank you steak and egg five
loving the subs guys thank you
so
not rookie seven that blunder's a rook
that blunder's a rook
knight e8 very good realm loops you
earned yourself a sub 98
now you're threatening mate on g7 but no
problem right black defends it with rook
f7
and now what
now where do we go from here looks like
a dead end jacob 778 with a prime
what do we do now
if you've been paying attention to my
speedrun game then you should already be
looking at this move
we sacked whoops sorry we sacked the
queen
and after knight f6 the difference is
that here black has the h8 square but
the other difference thank you curious
gifting to rem loops is that rookie 8
shack leads to force mate
whatever you cover with eventually rook
takes g8 is going to be arabian mate
so
cool little
example very similar pattern
very similar pattern
here
the rook is covering the h1 square
so in any case
knowing mating patterns it really helps
so rook a3 unfortunately like here it's
impossible to set it up because the
other rook is going to be guarding f3
even if you get one of the rooks off of
the off of the square so we decided to
essentially just go rook b2 and win the
queen
and if the queen moves then rook takes
f2 as checkmate once we won the queen we
don't need to go over the rest the rest
is simple
okay um
so that was a pretty pure positional
game moments to pay attention to first
of all e5 right you're getting move
ordered
all right well what's why doesn't
everybody play this well it's because it
lets us get the bishop out that's sort
of number one attentiveness to move
orders queen c7 not allowing bishop
takes c6 which doubles the pawn
um then 97 which is a little bit sloppy
i would actually say that knight h6
might be better because
that basically keeps the connection
between the bishop and the pawn
and it still gets the knight to f5
and bishop h6 is never dangerous i've
talked about this before but like these
doubled pawns are not bad because this
actually opens up the g file for you
and giving up the dark squared bishop
means that the d4 pawn is now a lot
weaker and that white has nowhere to
castle this is not bad for black at all
so maybe that was more accurate
then
not rushing to take the bishop on e3 and
using calculation to figure out that g4
is not dangerous
then closing down the queen side exactly
at the moment when it's least convenient
for white when white has played rook c1
now we play c4 and white has ended up
wasting a move
then not automatically playing a6 but
playing b takes a4 in this particular
instance
and i can also probably find examples of
somebody doing
this exact type of idea as well give me
a second let me see this is gonna be a
little more challenging
yeah it's harder for me i'd have to
spend a little bit of time on this but
in any case uh we'll save this until
later
i'll see what i can what i can find so
that's that we play b takes a4 opening
up the opening up the b file
then we get our rook to the b file
bishop a3 not forgetting about this idea
not forgetting that the rook is very
cramped when the queen is on d1
and now we just take everything and
bishop takes f3 etc questions
can anyone answer why c4 doesn't
marginalize the bishops in the closed
position yes so
as we move toward this level
more and more
you will find that we quote unquote
violate certain principles
now
look at where the bishop is right do you
does the move c4 truly restrict the
bishop
where it is like no the bishop still has
plenty of real estate right bishop g6
bishop has this diagonal so you can't
just say oh i'm putting a pun in a light
square
i'm closing down the bishop right then
you'll never be able to put puns on
light squares because they're always
going to block your light squad bishop
right so you need to assess the current
position
um
could white play a4 instead of b3
oh that's an interesting question could
why play a4 here yeah white could play
a4 here
with the idea a6 a5
but you know we would just castle here
and and b3 is not scary we can just take
it
and white's just left with a bunch of
weaknesses
what about d4 instead of bishop
g4 you mean here so d4 is a move
but d4 i think there is bishop b5 i
actually think this is theory
there is a line that goes like this so
you can look at this on your own i'm not
sure what the eval is but it's quite
possible that d4 is also good
does putting the rook on b3 or b4 matter
when doubling the rooks on the b file i
thought putting it on b4 might have been
better because it put pressure on the
eight pawn wait i thought there was a
pawn on c3 now
oh no no we took it already
uh so
the reason i like b3 is because it's
anchored by a pawn
i prefer to put rooks on squares where
they're anchored by puns any time like
right before maybe a little bit awkward
because also you're closing out the
bishop and why can play something like
rook c2 and then you're gonna have to
play rook b3 anyway
so rook b4 closes the bishop and rook b3
somebody pointed this out this also
defends the bishop so it eliminates that
headache if that makes sense
pawns are the best defenders of pieces
why b takes a4 better than c takes b3
so c takes b3 white plays a takes b5
and this allows like the opportunity to
potentially trade queens which i really
didn't want i wanted to keep the queens
on the board because i could sense
that keeping the queens just would
accelerate the the pressure but
obviously this is also good i mean takes
takes takes
and then you could start pushing your
passer i mean
black is just much much better here as
well so yeah c c b is an alternative
c b is an alternative
um
but i i liked the concept of pressuring
him down the b file i could i saw that
and then i just and i liked the pawn on
c4 because this pawn restricts white's
pieces tremendously it prevents any
piece from reaching b3 or d3 so it's a
thorn in white's side
in the beginning you were concerned
about doubledc pawns but doesn't having
two c puns let you play c5 twice and get
a big center so
i like that you're applying a concept
that we talked about let's
let's examine this position for a second
if white already had played d4
then i would agree with you because
hypothetically here you could take and
then push the other pawn to c5
but white doesn't have to play d4 here
white can actually play the move d3 and
then you're kind of stuck with these
weak pawns and white can immediately
start attacking them by playing queen a4
and the other pawn the one on c5 the one
in green in green
or blue or whatever
trying to get green there can be
attacked by a bishop from e3 and then
the knight can move over to b3 i've lost
a lot of games like this
um this particular structure i i don't
love
but like this exact structure i don't
really like
and i've gotten a lot of games where i
get the structure and then my queen side
pawns get attacked
i can i can show you this time i have an
example on hand
now i ended up winning the game that i'm
about to show you with a very nice
combination but
it's the first part of the game
that is important here
basically we got a grand prix attack and
in this position
i decided that i'm not going to play
bishop d7 i'm going to play bishop g7
and then i'm going to play e6 and i
tried to sneak it by him i'm like oh i'm
going to play 97 and then i'm going to
be fine but no he was not deterred he
took on c6 and you can see i got that
structure
and i i hated this like d5 e5 i went c4
trying to
like trying to
you know get rid of the weak pawns but
this is just not good
and instead of taking on c4 my opponent
could have actually gone bishop e3 and
then stuck that bishop into c5 and you
can see how paralyzed black becomes
so this structure is very very dubious
in most cases and you could do some of
your own investigation if you want but
you can take my word for it
okay so i hope that explanation makes
partial sense
and that's about it that's where we're
going to stop guys i'm pretty exhausted
so i hope i answered most questions
um
yeah this game was all about structures
and understanding pressure and
positional concepts and these concepts
are challenging especially if you're you
know 12 1300 some of this might seem a
little bit overly abstract to you and
that's okay as long as you sort of
understand the logic and
it's important in your mind to start
filing away typical pawn structures
which occur from the openings that you
play that's not something a lot of
people do thinking about openings in
terms of pawn structure and i often said
that pawn structures are overrated to an
extent they are right they're not the
most important thing about a position
but as you move toward the intermediate
level cataloging what typical structures
arise
from the openings you play and what are
the typical plans based on those
structures
is a good way to
you know enhance your opening knowledge
and bring it to a very high level
so
this was a good example of knowing how
to
put pressure in this structure and how
to put pressure on the queen side given
this structure
so great great stream thank you
everybody for the support thank you for
all the subs
i appreciate it see everybody later
thanks again take care thanks for
hanging out
goodbye
[Music]